[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mystères du paranormal sont de plus
en plus à la mode en ce moment entre
fantômes esprits extraterrestre
difficile de passer à côté de ces
questions dérangeantes
en ce qui concerne les esprits plusieurs
phénomènes paranormaux inexpliquée
pousse des personnes a vraiment y croire
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment flippant
pour les extra terrestres la question de
leur existence est également sur toutes
les lèvres comme le pensent beaucoup de
grands scientifiques en ce moment il ya
plus de chances que les extraterrestres
existent plutôt que l' inverse
comme nous l'avait révélé le spécialiste
de la question jean claude bourret image
en est qu'on est les seuls êtres vivants
mais misère mais c'est totalement
absurde et oui quand on pense que pour
que la vie se développe quelque part il
faut déjà avoir un soleil comme le nôtre
et des soleils il y en a près de 200
milliards rien que dans notre galaxie et
que des galaxies il y en a des milliards
dans l'univers autrement dit il y a une
grosse probabilité que ces fameuses
extraterrestres existent c'est ce qu'a
calculé à très sérieuse agence
américaine la nasa
nous estimons à 60 milliards le nombre
de planètes dans notre galaxie
susceptibles d'abriter la vie
s'il existe une nouvelle question se
pose évidemment est-ce que mou dans les
écrins thérèse santé déjà paris des
témoignages relatant la visite d'ovni
sur terre sont extrêmement nombreux plus
troublant encore des humains auraient
été visités par ces extraterrestres
comme jean claude bourret par exemple
mais vous faire une révélation ce soir
avec ce que j'ai vu était mondiale à
quand j'étais petit j'ai été contacté et
a priori les extraterrestres aime
beaucoup la montagne c'est et en
haute-savoie c'était à côté de saint
gervais les bains les témoignages comme
celui ci sont loin d'être isolé le jeûne
n'est pas le seul prévenu
alors selon vous esprit extraterrestres
sont ils parmi nous
[Musique]
alors vous avez été très nombreux
on avait reçu un peu bourré pour son
livre contacter le smic et c'est vrai
que bon moment là par les homonymes
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a rencontré qu'est
ce qu'il a vu que j'étais rage des bas
côtés c'est très simple je vais le
réinviter si je ne sais pas maintenant
tout de suite alors qu'il est qui vous
avez vu qui vous a contacté à quelle
heure dans quelle pièce et quand vous
les abîmer jacques l'émission bien même
c'est bien c'est beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai mais ce qu alors ma femme
s'est jetée sur votre livre est que sur
votre livre elle était passionnée mais
en fait vous expliquer ça tellement bien
je vais tout à fait franc avec vous
c'est la démonstration est tellement
évident qu'on au fond on est en bouquins
ibmp mais oui ils sont là sont à donna
c'est un extraterrestre c'est sûr vous
ne croyez pas c'est bien dit expecto
yalala alors en quoi cette année sa
terrasse
alors en quoi c'est un extraterrestre
dépend de combien de temps vous me
donnez je sais qu'il faut faire honneur
j'ai un petit peu j'ai un petit peu de
temps mais j'ai comme de la pub à lens
est donc là ça va on a le temps alors
pourquoi c'est un extraterrestre
et pourquoi chacun d'entre nous est un
extraterrestre tout simplement parce que
l'origine de notre civilisation de nos
civilisations
c'est un contact qui a eu lieu entre des
êtres qui sont descendus entre
guillemets du cosmos qui a pas d'eau et
de bain dans le cosmos m'ont fait pour
que tout le monde comprenne bien
ils sont descendus du ciel ils ont eu
contact avec nos ancêtres ils ont
amélioré nos ancêtres et l'adn qui est
en chacun d'entre nous vient des étoiles
et il suffit de lire si vous êtes juifs
chrétiens protestants musulmans hindous
vous lisez le livre sacré qui est le
vôtre à ce que chacun est dans sa
religion parce que les parents étaient
dans cette manne est donc moi dans l'adn
ya quelques ya des millions d'années on
m'a dit tu veux divorcer votre ça va te
coûter 1
j'ai dis pas le champagne lancé c'est
vraiment de la merde que j'ai eu moi
merci non non non vous avez une chance
insolente c'est que vous présenter une
émission qui touche beaucoup les jeunes
et j'ai été très frappé par l'impact
incroyable de l'émission dans laquelle
je suis passé vous démontrez tout ça
alors bon parfois c'est impeut c'est un
fait il faut se plonger dedans encore
une sa peau et isolé rythme et en quoi
hanouna et ex terrestre alors quoi ne
l'a été que ça tirait s'il n'est pas
plus ni moins extraterrestre que vous
simplement il y assure la planète terre
des terriens qui savent pertinemment
qu'ils sont des descendants d'un contact
qui a eu lieu entre une civilisation
extraterrestre et nos ancêtres et vous
avez par exemple je les cite est un peu
la dernière fois mais puisqu'on à
quelques secondes de plus je vais le
préciser un petit peu davantage la
dernière religion qui est arrivé sur
terre c'est l'islam mahomet est mort le
8 juin à 632 je vous crois ils ne
savaient ni lire ni écrire
et quand il est mort il n'avait pas
encore écrit le coran mais il avait des
passionnés autour de lui qui prenait des
notes sur des omoplates de chameau et
c'est le coran c'est pas exactement
qu'il a écrit bon les croyants 10 et
directement la parole de dieu mais la
parole de dieu sait quoi dans le coran
c'est la sourate 53 c'est la raison pour
laquelle surtout les drapeaux des pays
musulmans vous avez à 302 lune et une
étoile pourquoi parce que mahomet décrit
dans la sourate 53 l'a lu et qui descend
du ciel mais avec un intérieur quelqu'un
qui lui parle et qui lui dit je suis
l'envoyé de dieu tu vas écrire ce que
j'ai à te dire eddy seigneur je ne sais
pas écrire
elle a écrit je ne sais pas écrire à
temps écrit je ne sais pas écrire dix
bombes naturellement voir là c'est
intéressant mais on n'est pas quand même
dans du fort et concret contre et je
veux savoir comment je reconnais je veux
savoir à qui faire la main ce que c'est
ça la main de rethel jeu ça va
la voici j'aime beaucoup 54 et c'est
très bien 23 mai mais moi je veux savoir
parce que je me sens à qui j'ai affaire
n'a pas pu croiser ici tu le reconnais à
moyen terme je clique moi j'étais
interloqué par effectivement là là on va
dire de l'imprégnation dans les dents
dans les gènes fabre n'est pas ce qui
peut se passer avant ça je vous ai
rejoins sur ça mais moi je veux savoir
comment
qu'est-ce qui est maintenant là je
savoir pourquoi anne marie l'est pas
comme nous bon d'accord mais pas que
nous là mais il y en ad'autres même
gainey ça m'intéresse pas comme moi
abbas alors d'abord hanoune a beaucoup
de talent puisque
[Rires]
[Musique]
si la différence est essentielle puis
qu'il y as entre hanouna et chacun
d'entre nous parce qu'il a un talent
vraiment au dessus de au dessus de la
moyenne mais surtout je crois que le
plus grand talent days luna c'est quand
il a créé touche pas à mon poste sur
france 4 il était venu me chercher il
avait senti que je l'avais reconnu des
refaire vous n'êtes vous donc vous
n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes
pas terrien
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un lien avec la soupe aux choux
blague à part on plaisante on est au
coeur de notre civilisation là on fait
tout un cinéma sur le foulard etc
si les gens se baladent en supplie les
gens savaient quelle est l'origine de
leur religion
quel qu'il soit on sait tous frères et
soeurs ya pas très juste on a on a 30
secondes
donc vous vous avez été contacté petits
mélissa dernière fois on vous a fait un
message non j'ai été contacté et j'ai
toujours dit que je ne dirais pas c'est
dans mon coeur c'est grave et
profondément mais vous ne certifié auger
j'ai eu je devais avoir 6 ans ou sept
ans c'était la lisière d'une forêt j'ai
je sortais à s'ingérer des bas et j'ai
vu ce qui reste gravé dans ma mémoire et
qui avait sans doute une ombre
protectrice qui émettait la peur et je
je ressens encore cette peur qui n'a
rien à voir avec vous êtes dans un
couloir la lumière s'éteint vous avez un
copain qui sort avec havas qui fait ou
comme ça vous avez peur ça n'a rien à
voir avec ça c'est une peur absolument
s'excuse et j'ai retrouvé ça dans
d'autres témoignages notamment cette
institutrice qu'avec son mari faisait du
camping sauvage qui était confondre
confronté vers une heure du matin à une
sorte de humanoïdes robots dans la nuit
qui avait une onde qui sans doute le
protéger hélas une peur qu'elle a décrit
exactement de la façon dont j'ai
ressenti ma propre peur un bas côté pour
tout savoir
quant à cosmique jean claude bourret
franchement c'est passionnant merci
beaucoup